más de 72 horas después del terremoto
que se acudió el sur de Turquía al norte
de Siria las tareas de rescate continúan
pero cada vez con menos esperanzas según
nos explican muchos miembros de los
equipos de rescate las horas en las que
las posibilidades de encontrar a
personas con vida debajo de los
escombros son ya pasadas a hoy hay
algunos casos muy concretos de personas
que son rescatadas en algunas provincias
afectadas como en esta la que nos
encontramos en las Manía pero esos casos
son casi a cuentagotas y se pueden
contar con los dedos de una mano la
mayoría de las personas que aún quedan
dentro de sus escombros probablemente
según nos cuentan los servicios médicos
y de emergencias están probablemente
Muertos hoy mismo el presidente Turco
resetea y perdón está viajando por esta
región y está viniendo en estos momentos
a esa localidad de osmaníe no de las más
afectadas en toda la región pero sí que
ha visto como mucho de los edificios
probablemente un 20 un 30 Incluso un 40%
de esos edificios han quedado
completamente destruidos o dañados ya no
son ya no son capaces de albergar a
personas media ciudad que era quedará
derruida en los próximos meses y sus
habitantes tendrán que empezar de Cero
en este lugar o en otros una
construcción que ha criticado muchísimo
el pueblo de Turquía que se queja de que
el gobierno no ha tenido una respuesta
capaz en ni suficientemente rápida y que
muchos han sido abandonados recordemos
que en algunos lugares la ayuda ha
llegado en otros muchos no y mucha gente
ha tenido que ser rescatada por ellos
mismos Durante los primeros días o los
próximos los días después por sus
propios vecinos que no tenían ni
formación profesional ni ni herramientas
necesarias para hacerlo